décidé de vendre jeudi de grenoble vous
présenter devant les juges
pourquoi après deux mois de festivités
écoutez d'abord je ne me rends pas je me
présente au procès de jeudi tout
simplement parce que la dernière fois
j'ai décidé de faire confiance à la
justice de mon pays
naturellement il pas après deux mois de
clandestinité tout cela aussi parce que
maintenant c'est à la demande du bureau
départemental à la demande de tous mes
amis qui ont pensé que maintenant les
événements pourraient être jugés d'une
façon beaucoup plus objectif caskill
parce que justement il ya deux mois de
recul et qu'il n'y a pas ce traumatisme
concrets ces événements de le 25
septembre
est ce que les derniers jugements rendus
à l'encontre des paysans bretons par
exemple ils sont pour quelque chose
absolument pas je serai une injure à la
justice mon pays que de penser que le
procès fait à l'avance absolument pas je
pense tout simplement que devant la cour
d'appel de grenoble
les juges qui vont prononcer une
sentence qui vont me juger
eh bien le fonds en leur âme et
conscience tout simplement vous vous
êtes décidé à prendre le maquis vous
souvenez des événements bien à montalieu
exact qu'est ce qui s'est passé joueurs
il ya laissé passer que deux nous amis
avaient été arrêtées dans la journée
pour protester nous avons décidé de nous
rendre à la tour du pin devant la sous
préfecture et que devant ce succès
lecture manifester nous avons amené de
renseignements généraux avec nous il a
été relâché quelques heures après mais
aucune violence ni sur les personnes
physiques ni de déprédations d'un
matériel a eu lieu
millar donc pour moi il était exagéré de
parler de la nuit de violences de
montalieu alors qu'il ne s'est rien
passé du tout mais dites moi vous avez
quel âge à la droite hongroise
si vous deviez résumer la vie politique
de gerani que c'est quoi le côté il n'y
a pas de vie politique de gérard nicoud
gérard nicoud n'a jamais fait partie
d'aucun syndicat gérant d'un coup l'a
jamais fait partie d'aucun parti
politique je pense que à l'heure
actuelle il ne faut regarder que sur le
plan strictement fanny call et vous
savez je crois qu'il ya des malheureux
dans toutes les parties politiques et
qu'il n'y a pas de différence entre le
petit commerçant de gauche et le petit
commerçant de droite
pour moi il ya des commerçants et les
artisans qui souffrent pourquoi avez
vous décidé de vous avez comme ministre
qu'est ce que ça représente pour 20 min
écoutez vos moins 1100 rue notre-dame or
un citoyen pour moi le ministre
absolument pas d pas plus en sécurité
que le simple citoyen qui traverse dans
sa voiture un village non chaque métier
a ses revers chez nous chez les artisans
ou chez les commerçants
il ya aussi des risques du métier chez
toutes les classes sociales connaissent
les risques du métier il n'y a pas de
raison que les préfets les ministres
connaissent pas les risques du métier
qui sont parfois de se faire enlever ne
met pas fait vous irez dix mois en
prison
je n'avais rien ne vous laissera pas
disons que pour moi il ya une
éventualité dans les 10 mois en prison
je sais une chose aussi c'est que mes
amis font tout ce qui est en leur posant
leurs possibilités vont en sortir
ça peut aller très loin
[Musique]